it's been five years since FX is beloved
biker drama Sons of Anarchy ended and it
should come as no surprise that time has
been kind to the man who ended his run
at the top of the heap here's what Tommy
Flanagan has been doing since playing
Philippe chibs Telford viewers were
likely already familiar with Tommy
Flanagan's work before he slid into his
badass leather samcro jacket for Sons of
Anarchy mainly because he'd had quite a
successful run in big-name projects like
Braveheart gladiator in Sin City and
Flanagan wasted little time booking
acting gigs in the wake of soas
conclusion the first of those gigs came
via ABC simmering melodrama revenge bel
Flanagan only appeared on three episodes
of revenge he made his presence felt as
the nefarious mobster slash arms dealer
Malcolm black black was a key figure on
the series and he was also one of the
few bad boys on revenge whose
motivations were at least a little bit
sympathetic this is for killing my
daughter
either way fans of the series vividly
remember Flanagan's dexterous portrayal
of black as much as they do his grisly
demise Tommy Flanagan has played his
share of weirdos
that being said the actor got a little
weirder than usual for one of his post
Sons of Anarchy performances a music
video for new metal demigods Korn the
video was for the band's track rotting
in vein and found a dead-eyed mascara
wearing flanagan portraying a dapper
sort of bloke with a penchant for shall
we say the darker side of life though
the video itself is a bit tamer than
that set up would have you believe it
sees Flanagan's character kicking around
an unfinished house while huffing some
mysterious gas drinking booze and
playing with Ravens snakes and a bevy of
steampunky devices it also finds Korn
playing music that sounds decidedly like
porn which is totally cool if that's
your thing as for Flanagan he's as good
as you'd expect him to be and he's
definitely the most intriguing thing
about the rowdy mundane video like so
many actors today Tommy Flanagan has
made an appearance in the ever-expanding
Marvel Cinematic Universe and most
people would agree that Flanagan
supporting turnest Tolkien guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 ranks among the most
memorable
of his after Sons of Anarchy gigs if
you've already ventured into the goofy
yet surprisingly heartfelt deep space
drama of guardians of the galaxy vol 2
you'll remember Flanagan's appearance in
the film as a member of the yondu
ravager plan tulké was also one of the
most loyal members of yondu's crew which
is important to note because one of the
subplots of the film involved an all-out
mutiny among the Ravagers and those
Ravagers who remained loyal to their
captain didn't fare particularly well as
it is Flanigan's final moments in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 also
remained some of the most unexpectedly
touching ones in the entire film while
Charlie Hunnam struggles with letting go
of Sons of Anarchy have been
well-documented since the show went off
air it's safe to say that a definite
bond of brotherhood ran through the
series cast and crew as such some of the
SAMCRO brothers have continued to appear
on screen together since Sons ended that
said Tommy Flanagan's appearance
opposite his old biker boy buddy Charlie
Hunnam in 2017 s remake of Papillon was
hardly a shocker the film based on real
events finds Hunnam genre Papillon
cherrier attempting a series of daring
prison breaks with fellow inmate Luis
daga played by Rami Malek during one of
the escapes Papillon is aided in his
endeavor by a savvy gent with a shotgun
and face full of tattoos
he's known simply as masked Breton and
he's played by hun UM's former
second-in-command Flanagan after Sons of
Anarchy Tommy Flanagan joined the ranks
of actors who've appeared in Netflix
projects
unfortunately Flanagan's Netflix run
lasted a mere ten episodes with the
short-lived wu assassins that early
cancellation was likely more algorithm
driven than anything since the show
seemed on track to become one of the
more intriguing action programmes
available on the platform still it seems
not many people actually watched those
10 episodes of Lewis asin's which means
most missed out on one of the great
Tommy Flanagan performances who's too
late the series is set in San Francisco
and finds warrior Kai Jin who's tabbed
to become the last of the titular
assassins and restore balance to the
streets of Chinatown Flanigan's crime
boss Alec McCullough is largely
responsible for the imbalance on those
streets which puts him in direct
opposition to the would be wu Hiro
Flanagan clearly had a blast breaking
bad for whoa assassins and ultimately
delivered what might have become his
signature villainous turn had more
people seen it they say you can't go
home again
but Tommy Flanagan came home to his role
of Chibs on the Sons of Anarchy spin-off
Mayans MC and he absolutely owned the
screen when he did
while many Sons of Anarchy fans fully
expected a crossover episode when series
creator Kurt Sutter announced the
spin-off that crossover didn't actually
happen until late into the show's second
season titled COO cool on the episode in
question finds the Mayans crew honoring
one of Jax tellers final request by
sitting down with the SAMCRO brothers
and hammering out details about a
lucrative deal as you can probably
imagine things don't quite go according
to plan
even so it was beyond brilliant to see
Flanagan channel his inner cribs for the
episode and were sincerely hoping Mayans
MC can find another reason to bring the
great Tommy Flanagan back for a future
episode check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite actors are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]